JAKOB KALBFELL:
Welcome everybody.
My name is Jakob Kalbfell.
I am part of the Play
business development
team based in Berlin.
And I'm happy to have you
here at this late hour
for the last session of the day.
We call it the graveyard shift.
Please stay awake, bear
with us a little bit longer.
We're the only three people
between you and the bar,
so that should
give you some hope.
There's light at the
end of the tunnel.
The topic of the
panelists have already
been communicated
to you by Tamzin--
driving conversions
on Android apps.
Now what are conversions?
Conversions are, in my
opinion, the essence
of what all of you
guys here are doing.
The best possible
outcome, the result,
of a good job within the
buckets of quality apps,
engagement, retention, churn.
If you get all of
those things right,
the conversion will come up.
However, a conversion is
not necessarily a purchase.
And a conversion can happen
all along the user journey.
Think about your own user
journey during a normal day.
You wake up in the morning.
You turn off the alarm lock.
You check the news.
You check the weather.
You check your messages,
your e-mails, your snaps,
your tweets, your
arranged dates.
You work out.
You pay for lunch.
You hail a cab.
You do some shopping.
You buy gems for
your favorite games.
All of those interactions
can be conversions
to the respective developers.
Moments of opportunity.
So there are loads and
loads of different types
of conversions on Android apps.
And in general, you
can categorize them
and distinguish by two types.
One is on-platform,
happening on the smartphone
within the app or the game.
And the second one is
off-platform, triggered
by something on the smartphone
or in the app or the game,
but happening in the real world.
So I had a lot of
conversations over last weeks
with developers--
what could be interesting for
them to listen to in this panel
and to discuss
around conversions.
And the statement or
the feedback reconfirmed
my viewpoint that conversions
is something that cannot be
thought about one-dimensionally
by us having one KPI.
It's a multidimensional issue.
And for that, I tried to
structure it in four buckets.
And again, I'm going
to put the fingers.
Number one is the basics.
So anything that's around the
definition, the prioritization,
the correlations, the
interdependencies of KPIs.
The second bucket is everything
around organizational issues.
So anything that
goes with processes,
workflows, team structure,
and so on and so forth.
The third bucket is what you
would have expected this panel
to be about after all--
anything that's
in-product optimization.
So UX, UI, behavioral design,
hooking, nudging, anything.
The fourth bucket is around
out-of-product optimizations
or anything that's
happening outside
of the product in the funnel,
influencing your conversion.
Luckily, I have found two
very interesting partners
that have an amazing story
to tell to all of those four
buckets, whilst at
the same time being
from completely different
industries, completely
different business models,
and different stages
in their company lifecycle.
On the one hand, I'm having
Niklas Jansen, who one
of the co-founders of Blinkist.
Blinkist is an education
startup based out
of Berlin that takes the
content of non-fiction books,
distills it into small little
packs that can be consumed
while reading or
listening to, and then
creates knowledge for the user.
Niklas is responsible
for product strategy
and ensures that the culture is
flourishing in his own words.
On the other hand,
I'm welcoming on-stage
with me Andrea Trocino.
He is the director for
technology, web, and apps
for ASOS, a multinational
shopping destination.
Huge business.
He and his teams are looking
after the products within web
and apps, and trying to
build an amazing shopping
experience for all of
their users globally.
So without further ado,
please welcome with me
on-stage Niklas and Andrea.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
Hello.
Cool.
Thanks for joining us, guys.
I'm actually going
to pass this on.
So we've had a lot
of conversations.
And by now, we actually
know each other quite well.
So without further ado,
directly into the basics.
Before I started
our conversations,
I thought that the
topic of conversions
could be a very easy one.
At Blinkist, you're trying
to sell subscriptions.
And at ASOS, you're trying
to sell fashion, right.
Now unfortunately, or
fortunately you could say,
I've kind of been--
well, this premature
assumption wasn't correct
and it's a little bit more
complicated than that.
Andrea, I'm going
to ask you first--
what are the basics of how you
look at the conversion topic
at ASOS?
ANDREA TROCINO: Hello, everyone.
And before I start, I want
to say to my Google Now
was trying to suggest how to
say good evening in German
and actually, I
already forgot it.
So that's a really,
really bad start.
But I think what I can start
with is first point-- that data
and machine learning are
much better than humans
at learning and giving
you the right inputs.
So I'm particularly
happy to join the topic
about the conversion
rate because it's
been one of my personal crusades
in the last couple of years
in my career.
For those of you who are not
familiar with an e-commerce
business, the conversion
rate is defined as simply
as the number of orders divided
by the number of visits.
And one of the easiest
way to win an argument
and explain to people like
Jakob how conversion rate is not
the holy grail of an
e-commerce is just
making an example of
if you have a company
A, making 5 orders
out of 10 visits,
or you have a company B, making
6 orders out of 20 visits,
you'll probably say
the conversion rate
of the company A is better.
But actually, if you
really think about it
for like 2 or 3 seconds,
you will probably
want to imitate the company
B. Because it doesn't matter
how many visits you get, it
doesn't matter how many orders
you get, as long as get
the most of both of them.
So that's why I think conversion
rate has to be put in context.
This is why at ASOS, we
look at conversion rate.
Obviously, it's
one of the metric.
But then, we also
care-- and actually, we
care most-- about
the engagement.
That's what for
our Android apps,
we look at active installs,
monthly active users,
the frequency-- how often they
come back to our properties--
and how much time they
spend when they are in app.
And then, you take
all these metrics
and you do your
product optimization
based on the customer lifecycle,
rather than a single metric
like the conversion rate.
JAKOB KALBFELL: But do you
prioritize them at all then?
ANDREA TROCINO: Yes, for sure.
When you are in a company
with 4,000 people,
you need to give a
clear prioritization.
Otherwise, you're going
to have bombarding
by every single person with
a top idea for your product.
So we give priority based
on a number of metric.
Again, that could be revenue--
from a revenue point of
view, from an engagement
point of view, from a brand
awareness point of view,
and also have to do
legal requirements.
We do a combination of
metrics and once a month, we
do a prioritization session
across the whole company.
NIKLAS JANSEN: I'm very
happy that we are not
4,000 people at the moment.
ANDREA TROCINO: That
makes things much easier.
JAKOB KALBFELL: So how does
this look like at Blinkist--
this user-centric approach?
NIKLAS JANSEN: So what
you said in the beginning
that of course, one
of our business goals
is to sell subscriptions--
that's true.
That's very simple.
But the way to sell
subscription is probably
much more complex than just
looking at a conversion rate
as a KPI.
So we don't think about
conversion as just one KPI.
We think of conversion as a
user journey, which starts off
in the app store
and ends at a point
where the person makes
a decision, OK, Blinkist
is a product I want to spend
money on because it really
brings me value and is
something I want to use
on a daily, weekly basis.
So when we look at conversion
or at the outcome of conversion,
we think of this journey.
There are a lot of small
micro-conversions along the way
and you can optimize
a lot of them
with the goal of
creating the outcome that
is selling a subscription.
So the way we approach
it is there are plenty
of what we call proxy KPIs.
So we think-- like caveats
that happen very early
in the funnel for example,
where we say if this happens,
a user is much more likely
to convert afterwards.
The conversion is the outcome
that we measure the success
based on.
But we would much
rather optimize
for micro-conversions
along the way, which
then lead to a subscription.
So for example, one thing
we tried at Blinkist
is that instead of
just looking at screens
of flows that would
directly lead to conversion,
we try to map the
whole user flow.
Beginning at the app
store, to the onboarding,
to the first user experience,
to the up-sell flow,
and really try to understand
what is the user going through,
what they are experiencing,
what is holding them back
from making a purchase decision.
And then optimize
these step-by-step.
And these optimizations,
in the end,
lead up to a higher
conversion rate.
And maybe it will be very
interesting to understand
how we work as that--
I think for product people, the
app store-- the app store page,
especially-- is something
you don't spend much time
thinking of because it's often
taken care by marketing teams.
We actually tried to bring
together the marketing
team, the product development
team, even the content team
to look at the whole funnel
together and then prioritize
experiments together
that would then lead
to a higher conversion rate.
JAKOB KALBFELL: And also
the formal structure
is then accordingly?
NIKLAS JANSEN: So yes, I would
say there are two ways we like.
First, the product
development is
structured in full-stack teams
around our main business themes
that are new user activation
and subscriber engagement.
So we want to
convert people and we
want to keep them as
a lifetime customer
once they're converted.
But at the same time, the
product development teams
work very closely with
the marketing teams.
For example, they
have weekly check-ins
where they look at data together
and prioritize experiments
to run.
JAKOB KALBFELL: OK, and
how are those two teams
staffed then, if I can ask?
NIKLAS JANSEN: The
product teams--
they are staffed, as
you say, full-stack.
So they have mobile engineers,
they have for-mobile engineers.
For each team, they
have a project manager,
they have a designer, and
they have a creative person.
JAKOB KALBFELL: OK.
Andrea, how is it--
now obviously, ASOS is a
lot bigger than Blinkist--
how is your
organizational structure
effected by the way you
look at conversions at ASOS?
ANDREA TROCINO: So the
numbers are slightly bigger,
but the concept I think is
quite similar in the end.
So we divide our technology
based on our architecture.
So we have a micro-service
architecture.
So we have a number of what we
call platform themes looking
after every single,
let's say, service
in the e-commerce platform.
So you can imagine the payment
service, the product service,
the subscription
services, et cetera.
And then, we have in
the front-end teams
like the iOS team, the Android
team, and the web team.
So that could bring a little
bit of more separation from what
Niklas was describing.
But actually, what we do
is we stitch all together
with our product buckets.
So we look at the-- as I
was saying at the beginning,
we look at the
customer lifecycle
and we split the our
activities and our products
in three phases.
The first phase is discovery,
then there is fulfillment,
and then there is retention.
The discovery is
all about how you
bring new customers or lapsed
customers to our properties.
How you show them what's
new in the platform, what's
new for them, and how
you can inspire them
through our content,
campaigns, and products.
Then is fulfillment.
Fulfillment is once you've
been very, very inspired
and you really know what you
want, what you are after,
then is everything starts after.
So everything about making your
purchase the safest possible,
giving you the most important
and relevant information,
like suggesting you
your recommended size
or giving you all the product
information, the assets,
videos, et cetera
about that product.
And then, all the
checkout process--
making it as
frictionless as possible.
And then, there's
the last bucket.
The last bucket is how
you build the relationship
after the purchase.
So how you can bring
back the engagement.
How you can help them to engage
with you like checking where
is the parcel, getting
what's new in the ASPS world,
what else can be engaged in
them from a loyalties game
point of view.
So all the activities
that are meant
to bring that engagement
back after the conversion
is already done.
JAKOB KALBFELL:
And so you told me
you have 900 people in
the tech segment in ASOS.
How do you make sure
that all of those people
then stay in sync
with this structure?
ANDREA TROCINO: I wish I know a
silver bullet for this answer.
So the reality is
we tend to do--
I'll say that we work
very, very closely together
across the business.
This is one of the
views of the company.
So we tend to have
a bi-weekly session
with all the management, with
the data and analytics guys.
We work on a monthly
prioritization session,
to make sure that we are all
aligned to the top priorities
of the business.
And we tend to use every
single tool possible, in terms
of communication, to
keep everyone engaged
with this is what's
going on, this
is what is going to be in beta
for the internal employees,
this is what is
going to be in beta
for new customers, et cetera.
So we're trying to spread as
much communication as we can.
JAKOB KALBFELL: OK, cool.
Niklas, actually, one
more question to you.
So I know that
traditionally, you've--
well, originally, you followed
the very traditional approach
in terms of team structure.
And you only changed
to that structure
you described recently
and that this was
a challenge at the beginning.
You want to talk a
little bit about--
well, first of all, the
reasons why you changed?
And then secondly,
the challenges
and how you overcame them.
NIKLAS JANSEN: Sure.
So I think the
main reason why we
did it can be summarized in
one word, which is pizza.
The long answer to
that question is
so we kept growing as a
product development team.
And at some point you have
10, 12 engineers, 2, 3 product
managers, 3 or 4 designers.
And the team just got too big.
And there's this pizza
rule from Jeff Bezos,
the founder of Amazon.
He says, if a team gets too
big that you can't feed it
with more than two pizzas,
you should split the team.
And we were at this point where
we said, OK, either we can--
we have to split
the team in a way.
And then, we thought, OK, what's
the best way to split a team.
We said, OK, let's organize the
team around our business goals,
or our main themes which are
activation and retention.
So that was the main
idea-- that every team has
a mission they can
follow and really
work towards a shared
purpose as a team,
and not only doing features.
I think is very important,
especially for developers,
that they know that the
features they're building,
what they're paying towards.
And the second reason
was we believed
that it could paralyze output.
So in the past, we
would always have
to prioritize experiments
either for conversion
or for retention.
And now, having two teams
that can run independently
allows us to ship experiments
on both sides at the same time.
Challenges-- of course is huge.
There's much more
communication needed.
Because suddenly,
you have teams that
run independently,
but still work
on the same code base needed
a shared release process.
And I would say, probably
the release process
was the biggest challenge.
Coordinating different releases,
different feature branches,
bring it together so
that you can, in the end,
release one version
to the stores.
JAKOB KALBFELL: And that
actually leads us directly
to the next bucket.
For all of you who
paid attention,
we just discussed bucket
number one, the basics,
and two, which is the
organizational pieces.
And we're going to move
on now to three and four.
So next part, the second
part, of the panel
is about the experimentation,
the nitty-gritty stuff,
and the secret sauce of what
you guys were finding out
during all of the
testing that is happening
at all times in your businesses.
So in product
optimization testing,
obviously there are
loads of different ways
to find success for each
of your own businesses,
which is why that the examples
we picked between ASOS
and Blinkist are only
examples to inspire you
and to take home with you
for potential opportunity
to test within your
own businesses.
Niklas, we've been
working together
a couple of months back, with
your teams and our teams,
on a project where we
applied behavioral design
principles that were
presented earlier
by my colleague [? Jenny, ?]
to your business
and where you did some
experimentation around that.
Do you want to talk about this
and I hand you the clicker?
NIKLAS JANSEN: Sure.
So I wrote one experiment.
I brought this mainly
for two reasons.
The first reason
is why it's very
interesting is because it
shows a change in how the way
we approach experiments
at Blinkist.
So in the past, we
have been focusing
on a lot of small
experiments, just
like changing one
variable at a time
and see what the outcome is.
But realized as a
company, we haven't really
found the perfect flow for us.
We thought let's try
bigger experiments.
Let's have something that
can really move the needle
and try more of those.
And we don't really care
if we change 10 variables
in this experiment.
All we care about is that
the outcome, for example,
the conversion rate
goes up in the end.
Because in the end, you can
make a lot of assumptions of
why something goes up, but
what matters eventually
is that something goes up.
The second reason
why I bring up this
is because it's exactly
what Jakob mentioned--
there are some psychological
triggers we analyzed
and why this experiment
worked in the end.
So what you see here is
all the onboarding flow.
This is what happens
right after you sign up.
You get in.
You get a 24-hour
trial right away.
You don't have to
opt-in for anything.
There is no strings attached.
You can use the product
for 24 hours for free
and after that,
you have to upgrade
to keep using the product.
This was great because
there's no strings attached.
It's very transparent for the
user what they can get out.
They can use the product
on their own time.
At the same time,
24 hours is quite
like it's not enough
time to use the product
and people were still
a little bit confused.
And what we mostly
lost is this urgency.
So people can use it.
They can come back
seven days later,
but there's nothing
where you say,
OK, no, I have to
subscribe or, no, I
have to re-buy a subscription.
So what we changed is-- this
is the new onboarding flow.
And as you can see, there are
a lot of things that changed.
The first thing is that
the layout changed.
The pop-up changed.
The subscription screen--
how we start a subscription.
So we promote them changed.
But most importantly,
what changed
was that we changed
from this 24 hour,
no strings attached free trial
to a 7 day purchase no trial.
So I'm not sure if I have
the right words for that,
but what Google
Play offers you is
that a user can start this
free trial for 7 or 30 days.
But after the 7 days or 30
days, their subscription
is automatically turned
into a subscription
if they don't cancel
within the seven days.
It's a very similar to what you
know from Netflix, for example,
when you subscribe for the
first 30 days free trial.
After those 30 days,
if you didn't cancel,
you become a subscriber.
So we changed this model to a
completely different free trial
model.
Longer free trial period.
It turns out ultimately
in a subscription.
We changed the UI.
And we saw more than 50%
increase in d10 conversion rate
and in average revenue per user.
The thing is we can't
really tell you why that is.
Like there are a
lot of the things
we changed, but what we see it
really increased the revenue.
So the takeaways from this
is the one side obviously,
it was like a really
large-scale hypothesis
we tested here, that for
us, worked really well.
Instead of just doing very
incremental optimization,
if you change the
flow, it can really
change the mechanics of
your funnel completely.
If you look at the
distribution curve--
so in the past, you see a
lot of the purchases happened
after the first month actually.
So now most of the purchases,
more than nearly 50%
of the purchases, happen
in the first month.
Actually, most of the purchases
happen on the first day
in the first session.
So most people
start a free trial
and still stick around
and become a subscriber.
So the whole funnel changed
completely, which of course,
is a new challenge for marketing
and for product communication.
But we now have a
new playing field
for what we can optimize from.
So we dared to do a big change--
I would encourage everyone
to do big changes--
and just tried to be
transparent, build trust.
And I think one big learning was
as well-- like the old model,
though we perceived
it as very fair,
users didn't really
get that it's fair.
The new model is a little
bit less fair, you can say,
but it's more transparent
because people are
used to this flow for example.
JAKOB KALBFELL: Very cool.
Really good insights.
Thanks for sharing.
Andrea, now at ASOS, I assume
given the size of the company,
there are always
AB tests going on
and you picked one
or two special ones.
ANDREA TROCINO: Yeah.
So I really like to make my
points or to win my arguments,
so I picked a
couple of tests that
are very, very controversial.
So please bear with me the
last 10 minutes of the session.
So what I wanted to
show you is a couple
of tests that were done
in the Android app.
And the first one is about
the having proposition banners
in the product page.
What we mean by the
proposition is mostly
referred to the
delivery solution.
And we picked a
couple of examples.
One is our premier delivery.
It's similar to another big
company called prime something.
And they is a yearly
subscription in which you
get next-day delivery for free.
And the second one was just
the banners say, actually
for your orders, you're going to
get free delivery and returns.
As you can see down at numbers
somewhere on the screen,
the first banner drove
a crazy amount of visits
to the premier
delivery subscription.
Now that tells,
obviously, people
want to know more
about the subscription.
And actually, probably
their awareness
wasn't great up to that point.
And the second, actually--
the second banner--
the free delivery
and returns-- brought
to a less engagement in
terms of going and tapping
on the banner.
But in terms of the
overall results,
the second banner was the one
bringing a conversion rate
increasement-- an increase.
So which one would you take?
I think everyone will
go for the second one
because obviously,
it's the one that
is bringing more money home.
But actually, what we did is
we went completely for option C
and we decided to build a much
more complex solution of having
like a segmentation
across our customers
and targeting each
type of customers
with a different proposition.
So if we know that a customer
has already shopped with us
and is most likely to be in
the premier subscription,
we serve that message.
If actually is a
brand new customer
that doesn't have
any history with us,
we server the other banner.
So that was the first trick.
Now the second trick
is about pushing people
to add to basket.
This is like if you talk
to every single designer,
they will always
try to sell you,
we need to make the main
action more prominent.
We need to have this
made very, very easy.
You know like, even if you
stumble with your phone,
you need to tap add to bag.
So that's what we've done.
So we've done a
couple of variation.
And for most of our
products obviously, you
need to select the size before
going to the add the product
to the bag.
So we're done two variation.
One was to have a sticky--
actually, it doesn't really--
I think we cut a
little bit of slides.
But basically, it
was a sticky button
to have the add to bag button
on one side in variant one.
And a sticky bottom to select
your size on the variant two.
Now the outcome
of both variation
drove higher
engagement with people
adding to bag because you
are making the action just
in their face.
And then again, if
you look at the KPI
of this test in isolation
and if you think,
my objective was to drive
more people to add to bag--
thumbs up.
Pick one, is a success.
I think number two
has got 14%, so we
should develop number two.
When you open your
eyes and you look
at the whole picture of what
are you doing to the customer
behavior, then
what we experienced
is that there was no
change in the orders.
And actually for an e-commerce
platform like ours in which we
have a huge variety of products
and our catalogs is super
quick-- so every 12 weeks,
we change completely all
of our products on the website--
our stock availability is one of
those things that triggers you,
a little bit of pressure,
in ordering something.
That's why when we add
something to the bag,
we reserve the stock
for you for 60 minutes.
So if you succeed
with this experiment,
you're bringing
people-- pushing people
to add more stuff to the bag.
They're not buying
eventually more.
What's happening is
you're reducing the chance
for other people to buy.
So all of this to trying to say
basically, when you do a test,
you need to be very clear on
what's the KPI on the test,
but you also need to have
a clear view of what else
is impacting the customer
behavior or the experience.
JAKOB KALBFELL: Wow, OK.
That's a lot of input.
Very good.
So we're at the end of--
ANDREA TROCINO: I think I
covered bucket three and four.
JAKOB KALBFELL: We did
buckets three and four, yeah.
We're at the end of
our time, actually.
And I think we should--
time's up.
There is the sign.
Perfect.
So that was a lot of input
and good examples obviously,
on how to optimize
in your product.
We didn't get to do
around the product,
but there is a
lot of information
on that as well that we're
going to release later on.
I think what's interesting
and I think that's for me
the main takeaway is
look at it holistically.
Don't look at one KPI and don't
isolate KPIs from each other,
but look at it holistically
and in a sustainable manner.
Don't maximize short-term
for one single KPI, that's
going to then decrease
other KPIs that you're not
looking at so much so.
That's my takeaway.
However, I'm 100%
sure it's not going
to be as clever as
your takeaways, which
is why I'm actually going
to let you close the panel.
From all of the things that
you talked about today, or even
the things that
you didn't mention,
what would be the one thing
that you would give the audience
to think about now after
when they have a drink?
Niklas?
NIKLAS JANSEN: I wanted first
to say good things happen
at the happy hour here.
But I think the
takeaway would be,
be obsessed with the
problem, not the product.
I think as product
people, we often
get obsessed with
the product itself.
But we should always
take a step back,
trying to understand what is
the problem we are solving
and try to put ourselves
into our users shoes,
and see what they
experience and optimize that
rather than what we believe is
the right thing to optimize.
JAKOB KALBFELL: Perfect.
ANDREA TROCINO: Last
session, last segment--
that's a lot of pressure.
So I'm going to copy something I
read in a book a few weeks ago.
The more you learn and
the more you experiment,
that increase the chances of
you making the right decision.
That is true for both
humans and machine learning.
That's why I think it's very,
very interesting concept
to optimize, test, learn, and
then go back and do it again.
JAKOB KALBFELL:
This is even almost
the final word for the
entire event, Andrea,
and that's Tamzin's job.
Cool.
Perfect.
Do we do questions or not?
No?
OK.
So if there are
any more questions,
please feel free to
find the two of them,
and me if you need, at
the drinks later on.
Otherwise, we're going to
hand it back to Tamzin.
And I thank you both for being
on-stage, and being our guest,
and sharing your best practices.
Thank you.